he's on the Hawks right now hold on oh
my God it's like Kevin Kevin hurt her or
something no no no no no this is uh
Tyler hands bro oh
um oh my goodness nope that's right
Hibbert oh yeah Paul George you know who
this is
um that's McDermott no no I know he used
to play for the Kings yeah yeah yeah
yeah you got it close all right what's
his name though
yeah I honestly don't know that okay
yeah I don't know that's a Shabazz
Napier yeah no no no I'll give you a
guess that's the G and the sun in the
league right now too he plays on the
Warriors
it's something yeah okay I'll give you a
hint his first name starts with the m
yeah Mantra is here there you go oh big
name oh my goodness I know him but I
just can't think of the name uh Michael
Beasley